e
e e
all right good morning
everybody welcome back to Transportation
so we'll see how Rusty I I got over the
summer summer months in the
fall um I for those of us that are new
um actually let's do this first why
don't we just start by introducing uh
ourselves to the rest of the
committee see I told you I was Rusty can
we please rise for the Pledge of
Allegiance
okay thank you for that representative
Hill like I said we'll introduce
ourselves briefly as a committee uh who
you are where you're from and believe it
or not I've heard that and I I I heard
this that this is one of the only
committees that everybody who's on it
wanted it so if you want to make a
statement on why you like Transportation
that'd be more than fine too we'll start
with representative pataro
good morning everyone
I'm very loud and sometimes I forget
that uh uh good morning everybody my
name is Seth Miller I'm a first term
representative uh representing do New
Hampshire the floal there WS 1 two 3 5
and six um I am uh also was very I am
one of the people who requested this I
I'm excited uh mostly about Aerospace
Transportation stuff but uh I know we
don't do a ton of that here but it's the
closest I get um and Al all bits of
Transportation are interesting to me so
that's who I
am hi I'm Charlie St Clair I'm from
lonia District 5
uh as somebody that uses the roads I'm
very interested it and I hear an awful
lot from my constituents about transp
ation issu so I'm thrilled to be back
here and this is the start of my fourth
ter thank you
sir good morning Charlie foot from Derry
Rockingham 13 uh my second term and I
did request this Transportation
committee um everyone grew fonded on me
last year both of the committee and our
uh organization heads and uh support
staff and I'm looking forward to this
year
uh good morning I'm uh representative
Greg Hill uh this is my I don't know
I've been here since 2010 um I um I also
chair legislative Administration so this
is my second committee it probably broke
the rule that I'm not I'm the one that
didn't request this committee I think um
but um I'm only here because Charlie
Sinclair is here and I follow him
wherever where I
go thank
you my name's Tod represent of Ted
Gorski I represent Bedford this is my
third term um it's kind of like The
Godfather every time I try to get out I
they suck me back in and canies take the
canol take the Canoles and um I've been
asked to be Vice chair again I look
forward to serving with the chairman and
working with the
committee my name is Tom Welsh I live
hookit um I represent hookit and
Dunbarton uh it goes by quick but this
is my seventh term I have been on
Transportation the whole time I serve
two terms as Vice chair and this is my
third term as
chair um even though I Transportation
isn't my career um it it's got wheels
flies or floats I find it fascinating
and that's why I've always sought this
committee I'm representative Dan be I'm
from Amherst and uh this this is my
third term and I my second term as a
deputy ranking
member um I come from a trucking
background and I have a private pilot's
license and I've been boting for a few
decades now and uh so this was kind of
an interest interesting committee to me
three year uh three terms ago but now I
come back because it's the best
Committee in the house uh and uh you
know we have a lot of fun here and look
forward to a great
here I'm Henry gon freshman
representative Goffstown New Hampshire
Hillsboro 29th District uh I requested
Transportation because of a passion for
it I I've driven truck uh when I was in
the military I had the expert wield and
track operators and maintenance badge
and I'm also a professional motorcycle
rider and trainer here in the state of
New Hampshire uh and a motorcycle
collector so I'm very passionate about
roads road safety and Road freedoms
hi I'm representative Drew Fox I
represent Keane New Hampshire and uh
this is my third term on the
transportation committee I asked for it
again because after two terms I finally
feel like I'm getting my feet wet and I
know what the heck's going on um and
given that it's also a feel-good uh
committee uh we're all about the safety
and uh of our constituents and our
people and that's a good thing
I'm representative Eric Johnson I
represent Lee Madbury and Dober W 4 this
is going to be my first full term after
having been elected in a special
election in March um they put me on
Transportation last term because I
didn't know any better and they did and
uh I decided to trust their wisdom
again hi I'm representative ponden um
from nashwa Hillsboro District 3 um this
is my second term uh prior to this I was
a 12-y old Ina city of nsha uh chairman
of uh infrastructure committee lands
buildings and so on so it's a good fit
for here I also used to drive commercial
have a motorcycle license um I've
developed in my years a close
relationship with like the National
Police hon police State Police
Department of Safety and uh I think this
is the perfect committee and I also work
for Hillsboro County Sheriff's
Department so that's two cents about
me all right thank you very much um just
for our new members we are missing a few
people today representative Crawford
Carol Crawford from I believe molon
borrow is our clerk she couldn't attend
uh our ranking member representative
Sykes from Lebanon also could not attend
today uh new member representative gas
uh oh no um sorry um Hamlin that's right
I spoke with him as well he had a long
time ago commitment that he had
scheduled couldn't make it but says he's
watching uh live stream we'll see and
representative Coker is also uh couldn't
make it today um so I as usual have a
checklist of stuff that we can go over
for committee orientation specifically
um but I'm going to wave that for now
because we have all our department heads
that we generally deal with um and I
figured we could just have them go
through their presentations first and at
the end then we'll go through some of
the stuff that's more more Tech
Technical and just committee related uh
so without any specific order other than
talking to them and checking their
availability I will start and ask the
Department of Motor Vehicles Department
safety to to get it started and again
the for for our new members these I've
called in today that the people are
usually here so you've got Department of
Motor Vehicles um Department of Safety
well Department of Safety is the
umbrella Department of Motor Vehicles
Marine Patrol
uh fishing game believe it or not we do
have fishing game here quite a bit and
Department of Transportation so those
are the uh the common Heavy Hitters and
transportation so all yours welcome good
morning Mr chair and members of the
commission of the committee I'm Steve
Lavoy the assistant commissioner at the
department of safety uh I want to thank
you for giving us this opportunity today
to come in and talk a little bit about
the department um we are a large state
agency um we have seven divisions uh if
you turn to page two of the first
presentation here it's a it's our or
chart that lists all seven of our
divisions
um most of these won't be interfacing
with um with Transportation but just in
general to get a sense of how broad the
safety uh mission is I want to take a
minute to speak about each uh very
briefly so the division of State Police
who will be speaking today in more
detail uh they deliver law enforcement
Services Statewide they operate seven
troop stations the Marine patol facility
in Guilford uh they also operate the
forensic lab and the criminal records
unit and the permits and Licensing unit
uh Homeland Security and Emergency
Management they coordinate the state's
response to all emergencies both natural
and man-made uh they also operate the
state's Emergency Operations Center
whenever um that is activated the
division of fire safety is the Office of
the State Fire Marshall uh their mission
is to prevent deaths injury and property
loss by promoting safe fire building and
Hazards hazard materials environments
and the division investigates all fires
building collapses and carbon monoxide
releases which results in a
death the division of administration
provides internal services to all the
divisions within the department they're
also um the area that collects the
state's road toll uh that's the gas tax
not the uh tolls on the T Pike system um
but that that's a significant Revenue
collection point for the highway fund
the division of emergency services and
Communications uh Opera our Statewide
911 system um they have two Public
Safety answering points one located in
conquer one in lonia and those are um
both um Geo redundant and fully
operational at all times so if one
system um has a disruption the other is
able to take calls without any
disruption to the
public the Division of Motor Vehicles
who's here today to go into more detail
they operate 14 locations Statewide uh
they're ensuring that all of our drivers
vehicles and service providers are
properly credentialed uh they focused on
providing exceptional and efficient
customer service in the areas of
Licensing and all motor vehicle related
matters and then last but last La last
but not least the division of fire
standards and training and Emergency
Medical Services uh they provide
accessible highquality training for
firefighters and EMS providers across
the state um all providers all Municipal
nonprofit private career call volunteer
um and they operate two training
facilities we have one here in conquer
and another one in Bethlehem to to serve
service the the North
Country our approach um with the
legislature is really one that that's
collaborative um we view our role um
with your P pending legislation to
provide information and data so that you
can make the best decision possible um
we uh we won't always agree there'll be
times when we disagree but uh we're
committed to doing so respectfully and
and continue to provide data to support
any position that that we do take in
front of the committee
before I turn it over to State Police
and DMV um I know this is a policy based
uh committee but I think it is important
to recognize the highway fund as a as a
key Revenue source to support both Dot
and the department of safety uh if you
turn to page three um this is an excerpt
from the state constitution that defines
the highway fund and its uses um which
is both for the um construction and
maintenance of public highways um and
then also for the supervision of traffic
there on there's also mention of the
cost of collections in here in simple
terms these are the uh these are the
costs or Appropriations required to fund
the DMV on the road toll uh Bureau to
collect those revenues so those come off
the top before the revenues are
deposited into the highway fund for use
by um those restricted
purposes page four is a summary of the
revenue collections at the department of
safety related to the highway fund so as
you can see the about half of the
revenue collected is from road toll and
also the new electric vehicle sech
charge which is to make up for some of
the Lost road toll revenues uh the other
half are primarily DMV related fees um
that are collected through the Division
of Motor
Vehicles and then lastly on page
five again we mentioned that the dot and
the department of safety both um are are
benefit from the highway fund that's the
primarily where the source of revenues
to support operations come from um but
there's also benefits to locals so 12%
of all highway fund revenues are
distributed um to locals for Road um
repair and maintenance through the dot
betterment
fund one of the challenges that we have
which I think is important just to
consider as you're working through the
session we've had a structural deficit
in the highway fund uh for at least the
last three banum which is required a
transfer General funds into the highway
fund to maintain the levels necessary to
support
um the legislative requirements for DOT
and safety um obviously there's been
some discussions about concerns with
General funds this session uh and so
it's un certain if there'll be an
ability to do something like that um but
that'll be worked out through the budget
folks but I just bring that up because
even though this is a policy based
committee you're going to see fiscal
notes attached to legislation um we have
a role in developing those estimates and
um I think it's important to have that
context of of what it means when there's
a reduction or increase or any change in
Highway fund Revenue and the potential
impacts those have to safety Dot and
then also the
locals um with that that really
concludes my uh opening remarks today um
thank you again for the opportunity and
Mr chair if if you're okay I'd like to
turn it over to State Police and start
digging into the part that you're really
here to hear absolutely thank you very
much thank you
good morning
sir um my name is Captain Matt amuchi uh
with State Police and I'm going to
provide
a
um an overview of the State Police um
it's a very diverse division um so I'm
going to give kind of a 30,000 foot
overview of the division of State
Police so when fully staffed the
division of State Police is comprised of
300 62 sworn state troopers another 40
um state law enforcement officers which
is your Marine Patrol uh State office
complex police force over at the state
hospital and another 300 civilian
support
staff the structure of the State Police
is breaken up uh broken up into three
bureaus you have the operations Bureau
the investigative service bureau and the
Justice information Bureau
so the operations Bureau is comprised of
um 83% of our sworn staff the majority
of our sworn staff is on the operations
Bureau It Is overseen by The Bureau
Commander which is our currently major
Brendan Davey there are three failed
area captains that oversee the different
areas throughout the state and then
there's a fourth captain that is the
quality assurance and compliance uh
Commander that oversees policy
compliance and Recruitment and training
the operations Bureau is broken up into
uh field troops uh as stated previously
we have seven troops uh troop a is on
the Sea Coast that is straford of
Rockingham County um Troop B is
Hillsboro and um a portion of Rockingham
County uh lower 93 falls under Troop B
Troop C is uh the western part of the
state Chesire and Sullivan County you
have uh marrat County Troop B which is
uh which is where our headquarters is
also uh located troop e is Carol County
belnap County and then Coos and graft to
make up troop F which is about 38% of
the geographical area of the state so
it's very rural um but it takes up a
very um large area of this state then
you have Troop G uh which is uh over the
entire State and I do want to speak uh
specifically about Troop G as you'll
probably be hearing from uh several of
them throughout this session and I
brought several of them with me here
today just to introduce them um we have
Captain Steve sloper who's the failed
area commander over over Troop G um
staff sergeant Seth Atherton he's the
assistant troop
Commander um we have the supervisor of
the automotive inspect uh equipment
inspectors the AIS um Ken
chaput so throughout this session you'll
probably be hearing um testimony from
from them and others from Troop G um as
it relates to
Transportation so Troop G is broken up
into three different sections uh field
enforcement so field enforcement unit is
made up of sworn Troopers and civilian
automotive equipment inspectors the AIS
were tasked with enforcing the laws and
rules governing the operation of the
1614 dealerships in the 1984 inspection
stations throughout the
state and 2024 the field enforcement
unit completed 350 dealer audits 449
inspection station audits conducted over
a thousand mechanic certification tests
opened 131 new Automotive uh dealers and
144 new inspection
stations um and then in May of last year
2024 a centralized complaint process was
implemented making easier for consumers
to seek assistance with questions or
concerns related to their vehicle
inspections a dedicated email and phone
number was created specifically for
Consumer issues and clearly printed on
the vehicle inspection report provided
to each consumer at the time of their
inspection each complaint is collected
tracked and disseminated for further
investigation when
appropriate uh Troop G is also um
overseas the commercial motor vehicle
inspections so it enforces all Federal
Motor Carrier safety rules and
regulations and State laws and
investigates all crashes involving
commercial motor
vehicles um and then there's the
investigations anything fraud related um
that is submitted to either the Division
of Motor Vehicles or the state is
forwarded to The Troop G investigations
for investigation so this includes
anything from fraudulent documents
residency fraud registration fraud
odometer fraud um Vin cloning and the
theft by deception related to sales and
distribution of Motor
Vehicles the next slide is just um an
overview of kind of statistically what
we have seen from the division of State
Police over the last three years so
looking at um data from 2022 through
2024 as you'll see um our calls for
service have gone up um over 20% over
the last two years so in
2022 we had uh imately 136,000 calls for
service last year over 171,000 calls for
service our motor vehicle stops have
increased drastically everyone's very
well aware of um that we're down as far
as Personnel currently have about a 17%
vacancy rate as it relates to our sworn
personnel we we sit at 61 vacancies as
of today um our high a little over a
year ago was 80 vacancies so even with
the number of vacancies that we have um
two years ago with a little over 70,000
motor vehicle stops last year we had
just under 100,000 motor vehicle stops
our dwi's arrests continue to increase
um it's gone up over 21% over the last
two years from a little over 900 to um
1147 last year and our other arrests are
up 33% so again even though we are down
um staff-wise our numbers continue to
increase um Maria Patrol falls under the
operations Bureau um Captain dun Ley
will speak to that uh when I'm done with
this presentation
here uh special services also falls
under the operations Bureau our special
services are are comprised of many units
many of those units are part-time units
they're collateral responsibilities
they're in addition to the primary
functions of our road Troopers and other
Troopers that we have so for example we
have a canine unit there's a full-time
Commander that's sergeant Gary Ingam and
then a full-time trainer Trooper first
class Kevin develin but we also have 25
K9
teams crisis negotiation unit the drill
team uh we oversee the D program for New
England uh that's overseen by uh
Sergeant Richard
peralt who is also overseas our sex
offender
registry um drug recognition experts
these are all part-time
additional responsibilities of our
Troopers currently have 24 located
throughout the state uh our bomb squad
is comprised of four full-time members
uh and four part-time
members we do have a motorcycle unit
that's primarily used now for PR events
uh they used to be on patrol but uh
years ago we went away from that so when
you do see the motorcycles in the summer
that's primarily for PR events that
they're going to not uh operating in a
patrol
capacity our special enforcement unit um
this is our Aviation unit um our drone
unit all the dignitaries that come in
they're responsible for ensuring their
safety they develop the operational
plans um and ensure that any dignitaries
that come into the state um are safe and
and that plan is is put into
place our special events Response Team
uh this is another additional
responsibility that we put on our our
Personnel um last year with with several
protests and the increased number
protests that that we've seen in this
state um we've increased the the numbers
that in this particular unit we went
from about 30 that were on the um
special events response team to 60 that
we currently have now so they receive
additional training so when there are
incidents at un or Dartmouth and those
types of things we do have the Personnel
that we will either pull off the road um
or call in to be able to deal with those
um those situations and then we have our
our SWAT team uh is also comprised of 25
part-time
members our special enforcement unit uh
last year they flew 102 flights of
traffic enforcement missions uh
resulting in over 3,700 motor vehicle
stops and as you'll see um over 1100
almost 12200 of those motor vehicle
stops were Vehicles traveling in excess
of 90 miles an hour and 119 of them were
over 100 miles an hour and this is just
the aviation unit that is seeing this uh
this doesn't Encompass all of the
division of State Police um and then
they flew another 102 missions with a
helicopter typically for um you know
search and rescue type
missions K9 unit uh responded to uh over
100 U I'm sorry over 500 calls for
service last year and again we have uh
25 K9 teams throughout the state this
does not include um our four or five
bomb dogs that we have
uh bomb squad uh responded to 555 calls
for service um and those range from
suspicious packages to uh dignitary
sweeps when dignitaries come in uh
they're responsible for those uh large
events they'll go and and sweep the
property prior
to uh the Justice information Bureau
that's overseen by The Bureau commander
who is uh major Chad Lavoy it's broken
up into three areas uh as well
communication which is our Dispatch
Center um again they received over
171,000 calls for service last year um
every call is filtered through our uh
Communications unit uh records
information which is our sex offender
registry uh criminal records and license
and permits and then the J1 program
which is the NCI program and the digital
evidence
unit and the third Bureau is the
investigative service bureau which is
overseen by the bureau Commander Major
Bill bre
um it is comprised of four main areas
which is our narcotics Investigation
Unit our major crime unit our special
investigations unit and our terrorism
intelligence unit we also have a a
polygraph unit which falls under the
umbrella of Investigative Services that
is also a part-time unit so we have six
uh part-time polygraph examiners for
criminal exams and all of our
pre-employment
exams uh the next few slides just have
some statistics that I thought was um
interesting you might find interesting
from our different um investigative
service bureaus so our narcotics
investigation unit is comprised of both
our Undercovers and our mobile
enforcement team um the the two uh
collectively um seized over
$96,000 in US
currency um they made over 270 arrests
drug related and They seized almost
hundred uh kilos of illicit drugs uh the
total value is just under $10 million
that they were able to seize in both
currency and illegal drugs and
weapons our major crime unit um
responded to 78 investigations last year
these range from our homicides to
officer involved shootings um death
investigations and other
investigations um such as Amber Alerts
silver
alerts the um missing person clearing
house falls under the major crime
inbrella um our Cold Case unit family
service section prison liaison and the
doj uh attorney general's YDC task force
also falls under the major crime uh
umbrella our forensic laboratory is the
Sole Provider of traditional forensic
laboratory services in New Hampshire the
forensic laboratory is separate into
five sections um it's toxicology
evidence control pattern evidence drug
chemistry
and forensic
biology in 2024 the laboratory received
just under
20,000 um items of evidence and received
over 12,000 requests for
analysis of those 12,000 almost 50% 48%
of those requests were related to U
toxicology for blood and alcohol um for
DUI
investigations State Police also um has
the executive security and state house
security um and the peer unit those fall
under the director's office they don't
fall under one of our three bureaus but
they report directly to uh the
director's
office so that is the division of State
Police um kind of in a in a nutshell if
you will um I too wanted to thank you
for all of your support I know that um
we constantly hear that the the roads
are out control um I can assure you that
we continue to hire um very good
competent people as you can see we ask a
lot of our people um they're given a lot
of additional
responsibilities and we refuse to lower
our standards you don't deserve that U
the public doesn't deserve that so what
you see uh representing the division of
State Police I assure you um is the best
caliber of law enforcement um that we
can find so with that said if you know
of anybody who would like to join our
ranks we are currently hiring uh our
next test is March 1st and we'd love to
have them so thank you very much uh for
your
time thank you very
much and I know these are presentations
but I still thought I'd see a hand go up
or two but it's fa quickly again we'll
have plenty of opportunities to get
questions answered but I know there's
probably a couple that are fresh and so
long as they're brief we can move on go
ahead 555 bomb squad Services um did you
guys have any blown in place or or uh or
disarms that are not
classified not that I'm aware of
okay I just have one the very simple one
yes sir um no motorcycles don't do
patrols
anymore no I didn't realize that since
the late 2000s I think we went away it
might have been the
um yeah 2012
um there were a couple of of close calls
uh from my understanding is why we kind
of went away from Patrol y um it's
dangerous Ro riding a motorcycle in
general uh when you're on patrol and and
traveling at high speeds trying to you
know catch up to offenders um I'm sure
that decision was looking at the the
pros and cons the risks and trying to
mitigate those risks and what are we
what are we trying to accomplish uh we
have a ton of success with the
helicopter uh well I'm sorry with the
plane our Aviation unit um as you can
see from from uh some of the data that
we've seen yep thanks do you know if
other states are doing that as well as
far as eliminating the motorcycle
Patrol that I'm not sure uh I know main
State Police has has done away
completely they don't have any um
motorcycles um not even for PR events
let alone Patrol I'm not sure I know
Massachusetts does I don't know if
they're on patrol or not but they they
have a pretty good motorcycle unit thank
you if you have never seen the state
police motorcycles on an exhibition I
strongly recommend you go see uh it's
amazing these these guys are incredible
representative London thank you Mr chair
uh couple questions one is on on Revenue
do we or these new toll boosts that we
have that are just drive through and
you're supposed to be going 65 when I go
through I see cars wizzing 80 plus do we
do we do we capture the those plates are
we able to or do we have a number of
vehicles that are absconding without
paying the to any anything we can
capture there so that's through Easy
Pass um it's a completely separate from
what the state police um deals with I
know that they do capture um obviously
the vehicles that are going through um
any violators they capture the plate
they capture the picture um they do
capture speeds but we don't have access
to that without um either subpoena or
search warrant really that's interesting
my other question is and my last one I
should say is
uh yeah I did have another question if I
might Mr go ahead represent
follow even if we were fully staffed
with the growth that New Hampshire is
currently experiencing and particularly
on our highways um it's very difficult
for the Manpower even fully staffed to
fully control the situation on
particularly our primary our cherial
roads 95 the Fe Everett 93 um we have
the one plane is there anything that you
might recommend that we could help out
with as far as tools or technology that
would assist uh particularly where we're
down
manpow
um nothing in particular comes to mind I
will I will say is since really over the
last 10 years um we've become very
specialized even more specialized than
we were in the past and what we've had
to do with many of these positions is
steel positions steel positions from
Patrol and put them into specialized
areas uh because there's a need um and
what that has done is it's it's pulled
some of our Patrol Troopers um their
positions into other areas um we have
great need um across the board
um we really are the the back stop of
New Hampshire law enforcement
so we were able to demonstrate that
there is a need for these specialized
units but that comes at a cost and that
cost
is in some some aspects our our Patrol
um license plate readers are down in um
Massachusetts uh investigatively we will
use those um when we're trying to track
suspects um if there's Amber Alerts or
silver alerts s will'll contact other
states that have those um license plate
readers that are at choke points in
certain areas of the highways um which
which is very beneficial um to know if
that individual is is heading in that
that area um obviously we we tap into
cell phones and try to track them that
way um but the more ways that we're able
to track people that are either
dangerous wanted subjects or missing and
endangered subjects um the better so
that is that is one thing that this
state currently doesn't have that other
states do have that is a good uh
investigative tool thank you thank you
Mr
chair thank you thank you very much
welcome sir a lot of information in
there and again there'll be plenty of
time in the future to ask all the
questions who do we have
next a celebrity in transportation is it
still Captain dun Levy or is it retired
okay so but you're still holding on your
position correct were your title yes
okay Captain dunlevy
welcome thank you Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is Tim
dunlevy and I come to you today
representing the Marine Patrol where I
retired a couple years ago after 34
years in uniform and I'm fortunate
enough that uh the department has uh
retained me as a program specialist and
one of my major duties particularly this
time of year is to serve as a
legislative liaison for the Marine
Patrol uh first I'll say that I I always
welcome the opportunity to come before
this committee uh I I think it's fair to
say that we've enjoyed a very good
working relationship not only with
individual members of the committee uh
but the committee as a whole and
achieving uh everyone's uh best form of
of of a
bill uh I'll be somewhat brief this
morning just highlighting uh the overall
duties of the Marine Patrol some are
very obvious uh some may come as a
surprise to you but most importantly uh
I think it's it's important to point out
our major responsibility is ensuring
that every individual that comes to New
Hampshire or lives in New Hampshire and
enjoys our waterways and our environment
our great natural resources can enjoy
the specific uh activity that that they
wish to engage in and often times those
activities are in conflict with the
neighbors sense of uh enjoyable
activities whether it be a person on a
person watercraft a fisherman around a
swimmer's dock a power booer a sail
booer uh the Mount Washington or perhaps
a boat race in wolfboro Bay those are
all things that Marine Patrol in some
way or another will will touch over the
Year by Statute we are required to
perform and provide three uh important
Services first and most obvious is to
enforce the criminal and voting laws uh
on all the public Waters of the state
and the public Waters the great ponds of
the state are those that are 10 acres or
more in size we'll investigate boat
accidents criminal complaints and any
freshwater drowning whether it be boat
related or not if it occurs on a public
water in the State Marine Patrol is
responsible by Statute to investigate
the circumstances of that
drowning often times that that carries
over with uh cooperation from uh local
and County uh departments and more
specifically the fishing game department
who oversees the search and rescue uh
particularly the dive team uh Marine
Patrol and fishing game are often times
on the same scene when uh under the
unfortunate circumstance of someone
who's missing or drown and a recovery is
required the second statutory
responsibility is to provide a an
education opportunity for the public uh
when it comes to uh operating power
boats uh we are in New Hampshire if you
operate a boat over 20 5 horsepower
you're required to have taken a course
provide proof of a boating education
course uh if you're 16 years of age or
older we offer those opportunities both
in the classroom and in uh online uh the
online option does require an in-person
final proed exam uh last year uh we
certified a little over 10,000 people uh
in their in their operation of of power
boats on our Waters
the third responsibility is to maintain
our aids to navigation on Inland waters
for those of you who are boers or have
been out on the water uh it's no mystery
that uh New Hampshire is uh not called
the granite state for nothing uh we have
vast stretches of open water that look
like they're beautiful uh opportunities
to navigate but in the middle will be
some of the ugliest Lake Bottom you've
ever seen in the form of Boulders and
granite ledge and so on and those those
areas those hazards need to be marked uh
our our unit is responsible for
maintaining just a little under 3,000 uh
aids to navigation in the form of buoys
flashing navigation lights danger
warning signs and uh Believe It or Not
uh Bridge navigation lights we actually
maintain the lights on six Bridges uh
around the state uh for navigating
purposes we are comprised uh in the
uniform side of the the unit with one
State Police Lieutenant who is the unit
Commander four Marine Patrol sergeants
and three full-time year-round Marine
Patrol
officers and this season we had 21
seasonal Marine Patrol officers uh not
unlike the rest of law enforcement in
this state we are struggling to recruit
uh and and to fill our vacancies I can
tell you routinely from the the 80s 90s
into the early 2000s the seasonal force
with Marine Patrol numbered typically
between 65 and 85 seasonal officers
we're down to
21 so I'll Echo what Captain amuchi said
if you know of anybody that's interested
I can tell you that driving a patrol
boat on lake winaki is better than a air
conditioned Cruise run 93
so for what that's
worth um always not always that's true
last week if you were assigned to the
Sea Coast uh the cruiser needed on 93
was more
appealing our civilian ranks are uh
compromised of 11 full-time people and
this is where uh it may surprise you uh
some of the duties that Marine Patrol is
responsible for we have three mechanics
full-time year round who are not only
instrumental in uh manufacturing and
maintaining those those buoys and AIDS
to navigation that I just mentioned they
also maintain 66 different vessels
Patrol vessels that range in length from
10 feet that being personal watercraft
up to 240t Offshore uh Patrol boats for
our homeland security patrol in the Sea
Coast uh and with that there's 135 uh
outboard engines inboard engines and uh
a fewer amount of uh trailers for those
smaller Lakes uh and ponds in the state
our officers trailer uh the patrol boat
and we'll hit five six seven different
bodies of water in a patrol day uh those
those boats obviously are mobile and and
uh those trailers need
maintenance we have four clerks who are
responsible for uh processing paperwork
related to the moing permit we have
Seven Lakes in the state that require a
permit if you have a moing uh we have
water event permits that are uh
compromised of slalom course uh permits
swimline permits uh fishing tournaments
firework shows powerboat races uh poker
runs and long-distance swims are some of
the fundraising events that we permit as
well uh we also um have a clerk that's
sole responsibility is overseeing our
commercial boat program the commercial
boat program uh requires a lot of
logistics particularly in the spring
when we inspect over 600 commercial
boats between ice out usually in April
and by the 4th of July when everybody
wants to be up and running by then at
the latest what's a commercial boat it's
every fishing charter
it's every uh kids camp ski booat it's
the Mount Washington uh it's uh the
Marine construction barge that might be
working on your Breakwater or or your
dock those are all by definition
commercial boats required to be
inspected on an annual basis uh and The
Operators of those vessels need to be
licensed uh and we test over 600 people
a year on average who are seeking to get
their commercial license the majority of
them are uh Camp counselors
uh for all our kids camps around the
state uh many of whom are international
so to get those licenses they need to be
in State first so there was a
significant push in a two-month window
uh in in late May and June uh to achieve
all of those inspections and
testings um interestingly when it comes
to our mechanics I will say that mercury
marine identifies the Marine Patrol as a
warranty center so from a budget
perspective because we are a warranty
center and our mechanics are Factory
trained any work on engines that are
still under warranty are recognized by
the factory and instead of a a warranty
rate that a a marina may get uh they
exchange uh at a at a prated amount to
our parts uh accounts so uh we have we
share a great working relationship with
industry uh when it comes to our our
mechanics the final thing I want to
touch on um is our budget resources and
I think it's important to point out to
you folks um because you hear from your
constituents uh as taxpayers uh Marine
Patrol's uh budget is uh has two primary
sources the first one is the navigation
safety fund which is a dedicated
revolving fund uh and its revenues are
generated from boat
registrations uh voting education uh
revenues and fees uh as well as as uh
moing permits our other water event
permits are free to char free of charge
to the public the second main source is
that of the um recreational boating
safety Grant uh issued by the United
States Coast Guard those funds are died
up among the 50 states uh those revenues
of which are uh excise tax on the
manufacturers of life jackets and
fishing equipment that I know fishing
game and and other uh outdoor law
enforcement and and agencies benefit
from around the
country um lastly I I'll just mention
our homeland security patrol obviously
since uh 2001 our world changed and we
have one uh Marine Patrol full-time
sergeant and two full-time Marine Patrol
officers assigned to our homeland
security patrol on the Sea Coast that is
a year- round Patrol involved in not
only the escorts of of valuable assets
coming and going from the port of
Portsmouth but also uh uring security of
those vessels when they're offloading
product perhaps in Newington uh we also
have perimeter security responsibilities
for uh Seabrook uh the tank Farms that
you'll see along the river the bcat
river in Portsmouth and Newington uh and
those uh Power generating plants uh
along that stretch of river as well as
well as uh Bridge security uh the 95
bridge between New Hampshire Maine Sarah
long and Memorial uh bridges are are
important infrastructure to our SE Coast
so that that is the 30,000 foot view uh
I'm happy to answer any questions you
may have and and uh we'll go from
there thank you very much sir just one
light-hearted question so we can can
keep moving on uh did you get any phone
calls about the second sticker this
year uh one or
two thank you again thank you folks for
your
time and believe next up director
morasco good
morning morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you so much for this
opportunity for all of us to come over
and um talk to you this morning about
the things that we do and and how we're
going to support you through the session
and uh and Beyond uh my name is John
morasco I'm the director of the DMV I'm
here this morning with some ex
exceptional leaders from our leadership
team um I'm proud to work with them each
and every day and on behalf of
approximately 240 full and part-time DMV
employees um we all are going to give
you 150% each and every day to uh to do
the best we can for you and for all the
residents of the state um I know we're
up against it on the time front so I'll
uh I'll be brief you've got the uh the
slide presentation here um you know uh
the commissioner spoke about the 14
locations throughout the state uh
generally speaking we do about 400,000
inperson transactions at our counters
around the State and um and that's a lot
of uh that's a lot of volume if you come
to the any DMV really on a Monday and a
Friday you're going to see that the uh
the lobbies are jam-packed uh we have
amazing people um that represent the
organization that do that uh public
facing work and um they have to know a
lot uh they have to abide by the driver
Privacy Act 2614 all rules laws policies
Federal uh requirements for certain
transactions um and they do a
magnificent job and you know one of the
things that they do and I want to thank
uh Captain Uchi and Captain sloper and
and uh retired lieutenant J oy and the
state police for a lot of the training
they provide to DMV employees on fraud
um and I just had a meeting um with uh
Sergeant Aron from the state police
yesterday morning and he highlighted the
fact that so many documents are being
caught um by DMD employees whether it's
a fraudulent social security card
passport um utility bill with the same
address things that you really have to
have a Keen Eye for that our employees
are picking up and catching and bringing
to the attention of law enforcement and
um and that speaks to their commitment
and um and what they do each and every
day the motto with the DMV is we work
for you every day we're working to get
to yes we're going to follow the rules
we're going to follow the laws policies
we're going to do everything by the
numbers but where we can go the extra
mile and help customers all of you we're
going to do it you know I'll give you
one example I get a um a text from a
state representative yesterday on
somebody who hadn't received their
license in the mail um I suspect that
could be a mailing issue because it had
been so long um but our new driver
license administrator Scott Milligan
sent the text to Scott Scott's already
last night reached out to the
constituent um already has a plan to get
a license in her hand to include
potentially driving out to Milford to
hand deliver it um you do so much for us
uh it's a two-way street we've got a
couple of bills that are coming through
this body um this session that are key
to the DMV um they're more than just
cleanup uh they should have been uh in
place some time ago but they're gonna uh
validate the receipt that you get when
you renew your license um that receipt
that you print out at home we need that
in law that's got to be a legal document
and I want to thank our representative V
for sponsoring that bill and a bill that
um when you turn 21 on the weekend um
and you renew online you're kind of
penalized because it's Saturday or
Sunday which means you're going to get
that vertical license in the mail and um
we get a lot of phone calls we get about
uh over a half a million phone calls a
year a lot of those phone calls can be
broken down into specific categories a
lot of times it's process like that
where people call and say hey I I
renewed online like you told me to um
but I got a vertical license showing
that I'm still a youth operator well now
you got to come into the DMV and you got
to pay the extra and you got to get the
horizontal license um so thanks to uh
representative V's Bill we're going to
be in a position where you can renew on
a Saturday or Sunday have a grace period
uh you'll get a temporary you'll get
your hard copy after you turn 21 and it
will be uh in the horizontal format so
that's I get that a lot when I'm out in
the boat when I get this position almost
three years ago that's a major question
people have and um that's a a great
change but without all of you and the
support we don't make those changes so
uh we're scanning all the time we're
looking for how we could do the best uh
internally um and externally we work
with stakeholders I see uh Dan Bennett
uh is here uh Bob Scully was here Joe
Scully is son uh we work with nhada NH
MTA we work with so many organizations
throughout the state to um to make sure
that we're doing the best we can the
leadership team I'm going to leave it to
them to uh give you an overview of their
bureaus and introduce themselves they
have incredible backgrounds uh like I
said it's an honor to be with them each
and every day
um projects I'll just touch on briefly
um we have one going on right now it's
probably uh well it's it's right there
at the very top of uh major projects
it's a new license and um we're actually
phasing in a new vendor uh currently and
um we uh you know we're going to be
producing um through this new Vendor by
the end of the month
uh that's the goal and um so we've got a
hybrid in some of our locations of uh
the current vendor uh well actually
they're both current uh but one vendor
and the vendor that's being onboarded as
well and uh we're working through so
many things on that front it's going
well but there's a lot to it and uh so
our project manager for that is Ashley
Gray she's an administrator she's back
uh holding down the Ford on that um but
you'll see Ashley here from time to time
testifying and um she does a wonderful
job uh General lir is here with us today
as the administrator overseeing the
Title Bureau and uh etitle e lean is a
project I want to thank assistant
commissioner Steve Lavoy um you know all
the things that we do at the DMV the
wins that we put on the board um the
things that we're able to do there uh we
could not do it without commissioner
Quinn commissioner Edwards and
commissioner Lavoy who's really part of
the fabric of what we do each and every
day to include these projects and
another big one that's going on is uh
we're looking to um with approval to
make a move to a new location in Raymond
um which would take us out of that
co-located facility nepping which is a
busy one and it's really tight and it's
uh it's it's a bit outdated so um we're
hoping to uh potentially be in a new
location in Rayman off of 101 um maybe
uh you know in the the spring early
summer so um those are some things that
we're looking forward to um you can see
on page 10 our statistics speak for
themselves uh like I said the uh the
call volume uh we have a handful of
people that answer calls throughout the
division uh they do a great job AC Lavoy
has worked with our assistant director
Jen Bailey who's seated behind me on um
upgrading our phone system we hear that
from people uh our Municipal agents
throughout the state maybe oh that's on
the other side of the wall um I was
going to say is that door open um but uh
it's it's uh we get asked a lot about
our phone system and um what we're doing
now is uh we're upgrading to a modern
system and uh I want to thank the
commissioner's office and Jen for making
that happen for us so that'll help us
address the calls better um we talked
about the uh the walk-ins uh you can see
the online transactions that we have uh
over to the uh to the right titles um
you know right around 400,000 titles
issued um every year that's a huge
number uh every single one of those
title applications and titles has to be
uh manually inspected um that's a lot
that's a lot to ask of a small group of
people um and if you look at the
turnaround times on the numbers uh it's
fantastic what they're able to pull off
each and every day but etitle and Ean is
going to help with that as well um a
little over 1 million active driver
licenses throughout the state uh we
issue about uh anywhere from 330 to
360,000 licenses a year uh I want to let
you know that's done by um two
full-timers and a part-timer uh that do
that on site and uh we couldn't ask for
better employees than than those three
um they take so much pride in their work
and they um they're they're good for um
producing about anywhere from 1800 to
2200 licenses a day and they too have to
be manually inspected before they're uh
put into the mailer and they go out to
our constituents around the state uh 1.4
million registrations uh DMV rule sets
we have a lot of rules at the DMV we
work with jail car a lot and I'm proud
to say over the last three years we've
made a lot of changes to rules and law
uh to make sure that we're providing the
best service that we can um we're going
through all of our forms uh within the
DMV that's been an ongoing project we
actually have a part-time employee that
we've hired who is spearheading that and
we're making great progress to make sure
that we're always in compliance uh with
jail car um so how do you deliver that
great service you do it with a great
culture and I want to recognize all of
our supervisors throughout the
organization um for providing for an
incredible retention rate incredible
harvesting that knowledge Mak making
sure that people know that they're
valued and people come to work every day
with a with a mindset of we work for you
and and we want to do the best we can
for you uh but it starts with employee
Safety and Security uh I've made that a
top priority over my last three years
um and uh it's it's paying off for our
employees who come to work and feel safe
and although you can never prevent
everything um you certainly can take
measures to prevent a lot and that's
what we're doing whether it's a program
for uh you know glass at our counters uh
you'll see on uh slide 15 we have a
security monitor program that we started
uh we call them safety monitors now uh
eyes and ears greet people when they
come through the door lower the
temperature I was down in Manchester a
couple weeks ago uh Larry 30 years
military he's one of our security or
safety monitors there uh everybody that
was leaving that had already gone up to
the counter came over to him and said
thank you Larry hey thanks for the help
with the form hey have a great day Larry
uh it creates a different vibe and
environment and it lets our employees do
the job that they have to do times the
400,000 but it sets the tone when people
come in to have uh you know an orderly
environment for that 400,000 so um we're
about to hire our eighth safety monitor
um so they're in just about every
location around the state uh but we
invest in our employees whether it's
Columbus State training where we do
emergency preparedness I want to thank
the state police Colonel Mark Hall for
uh two years in a row allowing the state
police watt team to come in and train
all of our employees on active shooter
on the counters where they work to
include some simunition rounds that make
noise when they go off so that people
react and know what to do um to include
uh Justin cting from the New Hampshire
fire academy for stop the bleed training
for CPR training AED usage Naran
training and now we have these devices
in every location when you deal with
400,000 people you're probably going to
be put in a position unfortunately where
you need to Save a Life uh our employees
around the state can do that and proud
to see that advancement over the last
three years um and the list goes on and
on with the um some of the um safety
measures uh that we've taken and things
that we're doing um I do want to talk
about just to give you some insight into
how we think I think um I think that's
very important um we're always trying to
up our game we're always trying to put
wins on the board so things that might
seem subtle to people uh I think are
very important like when you send out
over a million pieces of corresponden
around the state every year um we want
it to read right we want the tone to be
right we want it to be grammatically
correct uh we want it to have the
information that you're going to need in
there to be successful so again you
don't have to be one of the half a
million phone calls that we get so
little things like when you send out um
a renewal notice making sure people know
what that entails what they have to do
um and until uh hopefully represent pres
ative V's bill passes if you're turning
21 on a weekend what to expect and uh
measures you can take to get the
horizontal license
um but we've updated a lot of letters
that go out and we've uh put a certain
Spirit into them that I get emails back
from the public that say I learned
something from that I could see the
difference in the tone we appreciate it
they feel like as they should we work
for them um licensed production time I
want to go back to that when I first
came into the position we were producing
licenses is uh 35 40 days um in some
cases we're producing licenses same day
or next day and all the credit goes to
the two full-time employees Bailey and
Alex and Dennis our part-timer who make
that happen um how do we up our game
commitment it's a noisy room there are
no windows they're behind a cage they're
producing licenses all day long but they
come in and they love it because they
know we value them and that's the
difference we go from 35 days down to
same day the other thing we do is we
work with our partners like at the
warehouse um well what are we doing
we're producing the licenses and then
they're going to the warehouse and then
they're going to a third party vendor to
look at the zip codes and then they get
mailed by US Postal Service why do we
need to do the ZIP code thing can we
take that out the warehouse uh said
absolutely let's do that and by the way
let's mail these things first class mail
so a state senator um the other day had
pulled me aside and said John I've got a
question for you actually it was a state
representative um who had said to me
when we were issuing the license plates
how was that I came in and got my
license on uh the 27th and I've already
got it I had it within a short period of
time it's the employees that are doing
that so um but we're looking at ways to
support what they do um CDL expansion
how can we make things better for
industry well we've got uh you know two
they're in the books uh a new Range up
in Lebanon uh one in eping and there's
going to be a premier facility up in
Bethlehem that will open in the near
future and um we also have a mobile
vehicle uh we have a Mobile DMV and
we're going to get the outfitted uh
technology in there which means we can
go around the state and we can do
license transactions in places like sebr
where we don't have a DMV uh or we get
calls for people who are immobile uh
well you know what in certain instances
we'll be able to go to your driveway and
we'll do a transaction uh for you or a
nursing home or a military establishment
um there are things that we can do and
by the way if you see the vehicle on the
side of it at the top it says just that
we work for you um little things that I
just want to touch on uh that make a
difference customer experience but give
you our mindset if you go to the
Manchester DMV I get emails on that
frequently uh I came in here eight years
ago and it was a disaster I come in here
now it's beautiful well that's CU we
work with Brady Sullivan the floors are
all polished there's new paint our logo
uh is on a branding wall new carpeting
in the back the glass we're fully
staffed and by the way I want to thank
Brady Sullivan for uh for what could be
anywhere from 50 to uh $75,000 worth of
a enclosure for a stairwell out the back
uh to make sure our employees are safe
both with a key card and for from the
elements and falling down the stairs the
coner DMV if you drive by um you'll see
it's all brand new out in front uh we
got logos out there that are lit up at
night um but that's part of the customer
experience and first impressions and uh
we want to make sure that we're we're
doing the best we can there so with that
I want to leave you with this our
commitment to
legislation um from the minute I came
into this position uh after a full
career with the state police I
understand how important your jobs are I
want to thank each and every one of you
for putting your name on a ballot and
for representing all of us each and
every day for virtually no money and a
lot of time and we know it so we want to
make it as easy for you as we can we
want to be available to you um so just
know behind the scenes here's how we do
it we track legislation well in advance
I've already got the whole list right
here uh I think Jim you said we've
answered about maybe 30 or 40 45 45 lsrs
um it's this leadership team behind you
that does that work uh with review from
the director's office before it goes out
to make sure we get it right um from
there uh we look at which bills might be
the most impactful to the agency and
that's where we work with commissioner
Lavoy and we talk about them and we
figure out uh is there a position do we
take one do we not take one do we offer
informational testimony written
testimony do we observe uh what what are
we doing on each and every one of these
bills that's a lot of time I have my
regular meeting with AC Lavoy later
today we talk about legislation all the
time um to get it right for you the
other thing is uh we have an internal
form um that all the administrators when
there is a bill that comes up that uh we
fill out who's it reviewed by What's the
title of the bill who are the sponsors
what's the status of it what committee
is it in what's our position if we have
one what's the recommended action does
it impact your Bureau uh does it require
programming changes technology wise form
changes website changes rule changes
operation changes budgetary changes any
other changes um but this is what we
fill out and we keep it and we follow
the bill through the session in both
bodies and then we hold on to it
afterwards because some of these bills
come back um but I just want you to know
that that's the effort that we put into
legislation anybody behind you you may
see this leadership team behind this
microphone much more than you see me
during the session unless you call me
and say John I want you there um these
are your subject matter experts they
know their jobs I trust them to come
over here and give testimony I'll be
here to support them some bills I will
weigh in on because they're of that
magnitude that I want to make sure that
uh from a you know the commissioner's
office as well we get a little bit of
emphasis on it um but but these folks do
a wonderful job and they communicate and
they keep track of this information and
um you know whatever you need from us
you just let us know but uh but with
that I just wanted to give you kind of
that quick overview and I'd like to turn
it over if I could to uh for everybody
here to introduce themselves and talk
about their specialty maybe Jen
assistant
director good morning my name is
Jennifer Bailey I'm the assistant
director of The Division of Motor
Vehicles I've been with the agency for
in my 19th year um in this role I've
been about six months but um I have
worked in every other area of the DMV so
I'm knowledgeable in just about every
transaction rule law that we um have so
my main focus now is I oversee the
budget contracts leases um projects all
of that um but again I am down here
often I was the last sessions um to
testify on anything that is needed
so that's
it hi I'm Liz mad I'm the administrator
of the registration Bureau um so I
oversee boat registrations vehicle
registrations um the international
registration plan the IRP for portion
trucks um also the issuing of dealership
and inspection station
licensing I've been with the DMV for
almost a year I came from Corrections in
California so um this is my first time
working uh in state government like
this thank
you good morning for those that are new
here my name is Jennifer oi I'm the
title bureau administrator I have 22
years of service with the division of
motor vehicles with a main focus on the
vehicle side of the house I've met with
a lot of you regarding uh different
regulations in the past um I'm excited
about this legislative season and to see
what these new projects take us thank
you good morning I'm Brandy cassida I'm
the administrator of the Bureau of
financial responsibility um our Bureau
touches just about everything that
impacts your Motor Vehicle Record I've
been in the position for a little over a
year and with the DMB for 10 and a half
years thank
you hello good morning my name is Scott
migan I am the licensing driver's
licensing administrator uh I've been
with the DMV for a month right now I
previously worked for US Department of
State I was s of immigration and Visa
processing as well as I was a
congressional post
liaison as well as immigrate uh
liaison hello um I'm Kathy O'Neal I the
administrator of um operations so I
oversee all 14 locations throughout the
state um I am over the safety monitors
as well so um I'm really excited about
um this legislative Fe thank you
no Lieutenant
o we could have him up here as an
honorary guest we sure could yeah big
part of everything uh and our deputy
director Janet bushard who ordinarily
would be here her father uh just passed
away uh within the last few days and um
she's taking care of her family so I
want to thank you all for uh listening
to all of us and uh happy to take any
questions uh first of all I'd like to
thank all of you very very much it's a
fantastic presentation I do see one
question if representative Hill thank
you Mr chairman and in an effort to
eliminate one of our bills um can you
give us a quick update on the blue
envelope program yes I can
representative Hill I want to thank you
for bringing that to my attention I'd
never heard of that program until you
did um and I've learned more about it I
want to thank administrator Ashley gray
for putting together a nice memo and
doing some research on it finding out
what other states are doing around the
country um the autism blue envelope
program is a great program it's an
opportunity for uh those uh who are
dealing with autism uh should they
encounter a first responder to be able
to hand an envelope to that first
responder on the exterior it has some
bullets of what that first responder can
do to have a positive interaction and uh
deescalate make sure that um you know
it's it's a it's good communication back
and forth you can put documents in there
when you hand the envelope over as well
um so couple things have gone on uh with
that I I I don't think we need a bill on
it representative and the reason being
is in speaking with the commissioner's
office as well um it's something that we
can do um so I've had the opportunity to
uh to speak with director skippa at New
Hampshire police standards and training
he thinks it's an excellent idea uh
We've pledged to work together uh to
come up with a program to figure out
both on the training front um how we can
do that for uh for First Responders get
the information out to them um and and
work with the office of Highway Safety I
talked to John C the program manager
there uh for production um I don't think
the envelopes will cost much it's
probably quite frankly something we if
we can't get the uh Federal funding for
we would look at our own budget for um
because it's just good customer service
so um that's a program that we're going
to put into motion and uh set up a
meeting and start working together on
but it's a great initiative I want to
thank you for bringing that forward
you're welcome thank you very much thank
you thank you
again uh next um how about Captain
Eastman from fishing
game I think I see one other then we'll
probably take a short break uh for a
minute while I track down uh future
presentations good morning Captain how
are you good morning chairman was good
morning everyone uh my name is Michael
lman I am a captain with the enan
fishing game law enforcement division uh
fishing game law enforcement is in
charge of uh enforcing all hunting
fishing trapping other Wildlife uh rules
and and laws uh we are also in charge of
enforcement for uh ohrv and snowmobiles
throughout the state uh we uh also are
charged with uh search and rescue within
the woodlands of the state as well as uh
dive uh our dive team uh makes
recoveries throughout the state and also
assists with evidence recovery um my
role at fishing game is the ohrv the off
Highway Recreation vehicle coordinator
um I oversee enforcement safety and uh
registrations uh so where you would see
me uh in your committee is uh obviously
the uh one of the things would be the um
the electric vehicles um if you know
certainly on the roadway they um you
know certainly evolving every day um but
in the uh off Highway uh realm uh they
seem to be expanding uh
exponentially um where a 14-year-old can
come up with $3,500 to buy a uh dirt uh
electric dirt bike uh he's certainly
more fiscally responsible than I was at
14 um so uh that's certainly one thing
that you may see you know some of the
personal um you know electric vehicle uh
legislation that's coming about and
certainly um on the the off Highway uh
side of things it's a lot different than
than on Highway um right now anything
with pedals would really fall into uh
that has an electric assist uh would
fall into into the mountain bike uh
realm but uh for all you uh motorcycle
enthusiasts anything that has pegs uh
really and his operated off Highway
would be an
ohrv um
so we also um over see obviously any
accidents that occur off Highway um we
cover about 60 uh to 65 uh accidents a
year um and uh last year unfortunately
four of the snowmobile accidents were
fatals um and I think that that really
comes um you know we have to look at the
safety side of things and and how we
evolve in that that realm also I I think
on the snowmobile side of things
accidents are becoming a little
different because um certainly we don't
have the snow cover that we used to have
and and people are falling onto icy uh
trails and now we're seeing more
substantial uh injuries due to that as
well so um really uh you know where you
will see me is in in those areas um our
officers we have about 42 officers the
couple throughout the state um and they
can cover any one of those things that I
described um certainly uh we as like all
law enforcement are seeing a deficit in
in hiring uh so like uh Captain said
they have a 17% uh deficit in hiring we
have a 133% deficit in hiring um so you
know very similar um it takes a very uh
unique individual um who wants to hike
up and assist a hiker in a day like
today on Lafayette Ridge um and then
carry them out or make sure they get
into a helicopter and assisted off the
mountain um so therefore uh that's thank
you for having me today um I have handed
out our ohrv uh digest uh to each of you
with my card if you have any questions
um one thing that is coming up here very
shortly is um our uh ohrv registration
is going online uh to make it a little
uh easier for our constituents um um and
they will be able to go on and do that
and and receive registration so that
they can operate within our state so um
I thank you all for having me today
thank you chairman Walsh thank you again
as always I see a couple hands we're you
know what I don't see the Department of
Transportation here yet so unless
they're in the hallway they are okay
briefly please Qui question do you have
any more of the pamphlets there weren't
enough I'm sorry I brought 12 so um I
will uh I will make sure you get one all
right thank
you representa pondon Mr chair very
briefly are we still doing Northwoods
law what what a great
PR uh so we are uh forever uh in uh
basically in syndication at this point
um but uh we are currently in talks the
same uh the same uh production company
angle entertainment um is looking to do
something more and and as we evolve now
I guess evolve maybe not the right right
word uh everything's going to YouTube so
uh there will be some sort of a YouTube
um program coming up I think
shortly thanks again Captain we'll see
you soon thank
you okay you
wantan ah I'll take credit for I'll take
credit for spearheading that by the way
and I believe most of the rooms got it
um I see if you can
just all right
um just uh I'm gonna call
up I was gonna call up Dan Bennett next
just because he said he was going to be
brief but thank you
Brad hold on Dan we're going to go to
the regular schedule we'll go to the
Department of Transportation first
welcome commissioner right
I didn't know if you were waiting for
okay ready to go very good well thank
you all for letting us give you an
overview of uh the Department of
Transportation my name is Bill Cass I'm
the commissioner with me today I have uh
several folks and you may see their
faces uh at the committee uh during um
during the session so on the far my far
right your far left is Dave rodrig he's
the assistant commissioner and chief
engineer next to him is Andre Brier he's
our Deputy Commissioner um directly
behind me is Steve lante he is our uh
legislative liaison so he would
generally be the point of contact for
the for the committee with the
Department
and um Lee barones who's the uh
administrator of the Bureau of traffic
uh tend to be several of the bills that
um um come before the the committee
would would be um Lee you'd see his face
testifying or answering questions so um
I didn't uh know what the committee's
favor with we can jump into questions I
have a very brief uh PowerPoint uh some
slides to just walk you through uh some
facts and figures about the do
as a general overview and then um we get
into some whatever questions the
committee has so um the very first slide
is our organizational structure uh so
there are three Commissioners and we're
all here today um underneath the
Commissioners we have five the
department has five divisions uh and
each division has a director so um and
direct reports out of the commissioner's
office is also our office of safety and
our office of asset management and
performance
strategy um and the the various bureaus
under underneath those um divisions are
are laid out there so primarily the
assistant commissioner chief engineer
kind of oversees the operational side of
the house that's our operations and
project development uh the Deputy
Commissioner oversees um the non-highway
and Bridge Transportation assets
Aeronautics Rail and Transit as well as
Finance policy and
administration on the second slide or
third slide if you count the the the the
front sheet is our mission and purpose
so our mission is to uh always strive
for transportation excellence and
enhance the quality of life in New
Hampshire and our purpose is uh really
delivering uh quality
Transportation projects and services in
a reliable safe and efficient manner so
some key facts about the do just give
you a sense of the size of our uh of our
agency on slide I should number the
slides but ke asks about dot on slide
one two three slide three is um we have
about, 1650 employees permanent
positions uh right now we are currently
running uh about a 25% 24 25% vacancy
which means that every you know one in
every four of permanent positions are
are vacant as we as we strive to fill
vacancies we maintain uh 2160 State
Bridges uh there are about 1,700
Municipal Bridges uh in the state of New
Hampshire are bridge inspection folks we
maintain we inspect every bridge every
uh two years uh every bridge in the
State uh slide four there are some other
just key facts about the department some
some some numbers we maintain uh about
4600 senine miles of State
roadways um we try to pave about 500 C
cine miles every year to keep up with
the overall maintenance we maintain
100,000 signs 96 million feet of
striping we try to stripe every road at
least once a year um and uh there are 25
publicly accessible airports 11 public
local public transit systems that that
we help um administer and administer
Federal funding to support
those on the the next slide um Slide
Five I guess uh with a funding summary
is a pie chart of our fi 24 actual
budget expenditures so the Department of
Transportation budget was about $700
million um we typically divide our
budget into two parts the um the larger
piece is the municipal Aid and
construction that's a lot of the federal
funds a lot of the other state funds
that flow to municipalities that flow uh
through the
department uh on the the other half of
the budget is what we're kind of
involved in now with with the budget
process is the Department's operating
budget and
um we are made up of multiple funding
sources as as highlighted there at the
bottom uh Highway fund federal funds
Turnpike funds other funds which is
generally agency income and uh we have a
very small less than 1% of our budget
draw on the highway fund that mainly
supports the division of Aeronautics
Rail and Transit and uh the larger
portion there the green half of that pie
the municipal Aid and construction
budget a lot of that is the federal
funds A lot of that is the Federal
Transportation dollars that we
administer as part of of our program the
operating side of the budget is
primarily supported by the state highway
fund so that's a very broad breakdown of
our
budget the next slide I'll just step
through the various divisions and tell
you what they are what they do so our
division of Aeronautics Rail and Transit
comprised of three bureaus uh overseeing
Aeronautics and the 25 uh open to the
public airports uh we are a block grant
state so we uh Direct direct ly
administer the FAA funds that come to
the to the state um and there are 12
federally funded airports three of those
commercial airports Lebanon peas
Manchester they work directly with FAA
all of the other um airports the federal
funds uh flow through the department to
administer those and there are 13 other
open to the public airports that do not
receive federal funds and we uh take in
about half a million doll in revenues
from Aviation registration fees on the
rail side there are six Active operating
rail agreements within the state four
Freight two tourist extension uh two
tourist Excursion rails um there about
150 mies of active used state-owned
railroads and about 300 miles of
abandoned railroads which tend to be
more focused with um recreational use in
rail Trails on the public transit side
there are 11 local public transit
systems um that we administer funds to
and help support as well as inter city
uh commuter service and the one bus
service that the department directly
administers is uh is the Boston express
running commuter buses uh down the 93
Corridor to
Boston um our
Administration uh division on the
following slide consists of uh the
executive office office um our public
information office uh and a lot of that
is focused on the management strategy
and the executive leadership of the
agency our division of finance um
oversees all um all funding and budget
formulation Financial operations
contract management all of the financial
um uh applications that come along with
the Department we administer you know
typically
around uh close cl to $350 million a
year of of um federal funds in our uh
Transportation program uh so all of the
bill paying and all of the accounts
receivable and accounts payable through
that um run through that as well as all
of the auditing functions of both the
highway fund portion of the agency the
federal uh program as well as the
turnpike
program and the other um administrative
division is policy and AD Administration
which uh encompasses all of our human
resources Bureau and a lot of the
federal compliance um office and uh um
activities that we do for occupational
health and safety policy formation as
well as employee training and with that
vacancy rate I've mentioned at the
beginning we are have put a lot of focus
on uh employee training and employee
retention and recruitment as we try to
rebuild and maintain our Workforce
the next division is the project
development uh division um that consists
of all of the planning engineering
support right-of-way Acquisitions
construction management of our
transportation program so those are all
the construction projects that you see
out there um our my my director of
project development likes to talk about
it is we are the uh largest uh you know
engineering and construction firm in the
state administering and developing the
state's Transportation program and a big
part of that program um becomes the bial
update of the uh tenier Transportation
Improvement plan that's our governing
document that's our legislative
authority to work on any of the projects
we don't work on any other projects
unless they're authorized through the uh
10-year Transportation Improvement
plan um we the bulk of our uh
Transportation Pro
program comes from the Federal Highway
Administration we administer about $225
million of um Federal uh Transportation
funds a year that's mostly going to the
um engineering design and the
construction of of those projects so for
broad perspective in FY
24 um we advertised about 84 new
construction projects um we provided
continuing oversight and construction of
uh construction projects with a combined
active construction total of about $800
$800 million so that was the value of
construction that we were overseeing
going on at any one time in FY 24 we
advertised about $331 million of uh
construction
work and that's all comes out of the
division of uh project
development probably the division you're
most familiar with or
or or see along the roads and highways
uh the orange trucks the folks plowing
the roads the folks maintaining the
roads that's under the maintenance and
Operations Division um so we have a
dedicated Statewide Workforce when I
mentioned this
1651 uh permanent positions we are uh
located all over the state we have about
84 different uh Patrol uh sections and
Facilities to maintain the state highway
system across the state we uh under
Highway Maintenance that's divided into
six Regional maintenance districts that
provide the um administrative oversight
of those maintenance
activities um and uh you know the big
part of our focus is uh particularly
this time of year is the winter
maintenance operations keeping the roads
plowed and cleared and responding to
storms um another big part in the past
several years has been the uh response
to emergency events there has not been a
summer and and even a winter when we
haven't had some some flood some natural
disaster uh roadway wash outs and it's
uh this dedicated Statewide Workforce
that are the front lines and responding
to those uh getting the roads put back
together getting traffic moving
again um so Highway Maintenance is is uh
and those are the guys in the orange
trucks that you see around the they're
um
they're the uh Forefront of the Highway
Maintenance activities but uh overall
operations activities are also supported
by the Bureau of traffic that do all of
the line striping uh set the speed
limits do the signs maintain the signals
we have a uh Bureau of bridge
maintenance that maintains that does the
routine maintenance of of uh State
Bridges um divided into 12 Bridge
construction Crews we have a Mechanical
Services Bureau that maintains me the
state uh vehicle Fleet and have uh the
main garage here in conquer but also six
satellite facilities that support each
of the uh districts and the um Fleet
equipment in each of those facilities in
each of those districts um many people
don't know as well that the Department
of Transportation maintains the state's
fuel distribution system um so we have
87 fuel sites maintains um you know
fueling our vehicles but also all of the
municipalities can can um um refuel at
our sites State Police uh everybody and
we are the um strategic fuel reserve for
the state as well and uh lastly uh we
have a transportation systems management
and operation center it's located
collocated with the Department of Safety
um police State Police dispatch uh and a
traff traffic Management Center Traffic
Management Center uh and that maintains
the um the eyes and ears on the on the
highway system looking out and managing
all the uh um cameras and sensors and
everything that we managed to keep an
keep eyes on the on on the
road so that's a general brief overview
of the department I have a few just
other um elements of the department that
I just wanted to point out the next
slide I just talk a little bit about the
highway fund and I I believe you heard
from Steve Lavoy a little bit more about
the highway fund as well too but um
there is kind of a misnomer that we'd
like to point out uh the highway fund
comes from the uh state road toll that's
the gas tax as well as the um um
registration fees and uh but even though
it has Highway in its name uh the
highway fund is not the deal and the dot
is not the highway fund uh Department of
Safety collects all the revenues for the
for the for the highway fund um and it's
the unrestricted reeven Revenue fund
that comes from those resources but it's
the legislator legislature that that um
appropriates the funds um and we are not
the only um drawer of Highway funds in
fact if you look at the stats at the
bottom in
2024 while it is our primary source of
uh revenue for um for our operating
budget um in
2024 only about 57% of the highway fund
was appropriated to do that means 40% or
or more you know went to other agencies
um as well as to local
municipalities
um but we do um like I said that is the
highway fund is is the primary source of
funding for our Rock operations budget
and to keep us
running the uh the next slide just gives
a quick overview of the turnpike system
uh which is an enterprise system so
there
areund uh about 89 miles uh of of
Interstate freeway facilities that are
told uh that comprise the uh Turnpike
system so it's an Enterprise System
meaning that the revenue that's
collected from those toll plazas like in
hookit like in Bedford
like in uh like in Hampton that that
Revenue that comes from those tolls uh
stays within the turnpike system and
goes to just maintain those 89 miles of
of uh roadway so we can't take and you
utilize uh Turnpike funds on other areas
uh or other roadways in the state so
it's a self-contained self-managed
system self-funded by the by the tolls
on those
facilities um so there just some facts
some figures about the turnpike system
there but in FY 24 for order of
magnitude uh they collected about $149
million of total revenue um uh out of
1188 million tot transactions along the
turnpike system so in the in the graphic
there just uh highlights you know the
the
um the toll system probably in this area
the the primary route North South 93
between Exit 14 and and conquered down
to the 293 split is part of the Fe ever
turnike that's part of the toll system
and then the remaining F ever Turnpike
goes down 293 and down the F ever
Turnpike uh to the state line uh in
between nashaa and
Massachusetts and on the Sea Coast I95
uh from from C Brook to Portsmouth is a
to facility as part of the turnpike
system as well as the Spalding Turnpike
from Portsmouth up to
um up to
Milton so very briefly the next slide it
just discussed some of the issues and
challenges that the department is facing
inflation uh certainly no secret but uh
inflation is uh certainly one of the key
issues we're dealing with everything is
costing more and we have essentially
level and flat budgets um it's affecting
construction work we've seen uh in the
last year and a half substantial
escalation and construction costs um we
are keeping up uh the additional Federal
funding that we got with a federal um
transportation bill um represented about
uh 25 to 28% increase in federal funds
um uh a lot of that has been absorbed by
inflation so we have a very sustainable
program but we aren't doing a whole lot
more because of inflation and that's
affecting also operation ations
everything is um everything is costing
more the salt that we use the equipment
that we buy and and things like that um
I already talked a little bit about the
workforce vacancies again we're running
about a 24% vacancy rate we have never
really recovered from covid so for the
last two to three years we have been uh
dealing and managing with things with
with that um vacancy rate it fluctuates
a little Up Up and Down but it seems to
have uh kind of been level at around
that rate uh and we have difficulty
attracting and retaining employees
despite uh a very concerted effort on
our part to rebuild the
workforce um and some of the
implications of that are uh in
productivity so we have performance
targets we have a lot of uh work
programs and and things that we would um
achieve that we would like to achieve uh
and uh we are falling short on our
targets we are constantly prioritizing
resources to address the critical needs
um and and one of the things I I like to
say that I the way I summarize it in our
budget pres presentation is that we are
getting done what we have to get done
but we aren't getting done everything
that that we should be because of the
because of our vacancy rates and part of
the impact is going to be some some some
future impacts it's it's reducing
preventative maintenance so uh we aren't
getting out there and Main maintaining
um the Mowing and the ditching and
everything like that that that we should
be as we prioritize resources to other
critical Life Safety
areas
um when you look at issues and
challenges the next slide is a is a
graph comparing our historic uh
Workforce Staffing to um vehicle miles
traveled which is a measure of the use
of our transportation system so you you
can see that going back uh 20 years or
so we were resourced we were staffed a a
at a higher um at a higher level um we
have continued to reduce
Workforce uh We've contined to try to do
more with less um and at the same time
the use of our system uh the vehicle
mile travels have been uh increasing so
I like to call this graphic our
efficientcy graphic because I do think
it indicates that the Department of
Transportation is is efficient we
continue to do uh more more with less um
we have not added positions in the last
10 10 years and we've been relatively
flat and stable and we found ways to do
things um whether it be with hired help
or consultant help or other other ways
um to maintain a stable and level
Workforce longer term challenges um you
know do become you know fund funding
issues there is insufficient Highway
fund revenues to fund current levels of
service um we do not match our federal
funds like other states do with uh we
put very little State funds into
matching our federal program um as as a
result our federal funds do not go as
far um but that's a decision that that
that we have made with with limited
state
but there are very very little State
funds that go into our um transportation
program and uh you know it is uh as you
look ahead and and forecasting we do see
you know declining roll toe revenues as
um fuel efficiency increases in vehicles
electric vehicles come online um so the
sustainability of the highway fund you
know continues to be a a question in in
in the long term
in the long term and over the past you
know 10 or 15 years every biennium the
highway fund has uh you know been
balanced our B our budgets have been
balanced through a series of one-time
fixes whether it's general fund infusion
into the highway fund or or other um
registration fees or charges or other
things that have been done uh on these
one-time budget fixes so um in the long
run I guess it's it's just that that
questionable sustainability of overall
Highway funding is is a question in our
minds so
um the next slide these are the types of
of things at the trans Transportation
committee that you all typically uh
interact with the Department on the
types of bills usually it's bills
dealing with speed limits or line
striping or seasonal postings pedestrian
traffic signals um
ohvs um drones or other aeronautic uses
those are some of the types of bills in
the past that uh we have come before
this uh committee to answer questions
and bills
on and um
um I'm not sure I haven't looked ahead
at what the bills are before the
committee but I'm sure we'll be back
before you for some questions at some
point um the last two point I wanted to
make um little
less pertinent to the transportation
committee than it is to say house public
works but every two years we update the
10-year plan so uh that is coming up
beginning this this uh this summer we'll
start public hearings with the um
executive councel um make a uh
recommendation to the governor by next
December um and ultimately next section
the uh revised or updated 10-year plan
will become a piece of legislation
coming before the legislature um but
that work begins um this summer to uh um
form and develop the the plan and and
part of that plan will be as I said with
some of the um flat or level Financial
Resources what choices uh we need to
make as a as a state of where we want to
invest uh those funding what projects
we're going to do but um I can tell you
and and you probably all know from your
constituents there are many more needs
than there are resources so those
choices become um uh you know very
pertinent and lastly I just want to put
in a plug for the uh New Hampshire um
transportation Council chairman Walsh
sits on the transportation Council so
he's well aware of it but uh there is a
transportation Council that was
established by legislature to partner
with the do it's made up of a number of
other um
um state agencies as well as uh
representatives from the from the House
and Senate and and and and the public um
and they're charged with studying or
investigating
evaluating um new Transportation
Technologies and and modes to improve
improve Transportation so I know a
number of times particularly in this
committee things have come before the
committee that may warrant more
evaluation more more study uh and I
think the transportation Council can be
a resource to the legislature or
resource to the uh to this Committee in
in researching or evaluating any you
know newer Technologies or or things
that come along that that could affect
um that could affect your work so I just
want to make you aware of that so you're
aware um and that's all I had from an
overview of the uh Department of
Transportation and certainly willing to
entertain whatever questions the
committee
has thank you so much any questions from
the committee representative
Peto thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
uh for coming taking my question um
concerning the highway fund uh talked
about uh declining revenues in one of
the previous presentations this morning
there was an illusion to an electrical
vehicle charge um could you describe
what that is yeah I think the I I'm
speaking a little bit off the cuff but I
know um and Dave if you you or you know
I know um I'll have Dave come up but uh
if it was last year the legisl did put
in a search charge for for um EV
purchases I think it was $50 or $100 I
don't if you know remember the details
yeah it's $1100 for electric vehicles
and $50 for um hybrid electric
vehicles so and I believe that generates
somewhere in the order of about $
million I know Department of Safety Conn
collects the revenue um but they I I
seem to recall about that amount that
that it has um generated to date thank
you gentlemen thank you sure
representative Miller thank you Mr ch um
your efficiency graph that you shared
with us um I note that you're using the
number of position itions as you're
Staffing not the number of actual staff
and with the uh drop in head count you
you say you're 24% down right now has
that 24% been consistent or is this sort
of hiding the fact that you have way
fewer people than we did 10 or 15 years
ago that it's actually a more dramatic
change than what we're seeing in this
chart that that's a good observation I
think the latter I think I think it is a
little more dramatic than this graphic
may may may imply because we have been
dealing with a um a fairly consistent
vacancy rate that we just haven't been
able to um um reduce it usually runs
between 20 and
24% it's a little bit amassing because
it's it's not um it's not consistent
there are some there are some areas
there are some bureaus that are fully
staffed there are some areas um where we
have even more inordinate um vacancies I
look at our engineering positions in
project development uh which is running
around 35 to 40% that's a that's part of
an issue with the with the with with
with the state and what the state's able
to pay but it's also um an industrywide
kind of shortage of Engineers coming out
of school as well too so I think
um yes from our efficiency chart it does
mask a little bit that we are uh have
have even less people than than what
what what we show on that chart
continuing to R to get everything done
thank you representative Pont thank you
Mr chair um on slide six I noticed that
uh we show uh over half a million
dollars in uh revenue from
Aviation but nothing I don't see
anything for rail or public transit do
we recruit any do you know any revenues
coming in from rail or or uh public
transit um on on on rail we do get it's
about a million dollars a year of
Revenue as part of the um uh operating
agreements uh for um operators and and
the and the Rail lines running on on
state lines part of that um is is plowed
back into maintenance of of those those
lines working with the working with the
um operators of those lines um so
relatively meager rail um
Revenue that that comes from that but it
is it is something uh public transit uh
we do not get any revenue for that um
yeah um BX uh the Boston Express
um uh line that that that we run we
subsidize that uh there is fair boox
Revenue but the fair boox doesn't cover
the operating cost as and and that's
been a slow recovery since co uh Andre
wanted me to make sure I mentioned the
uh the P3 we just recently had a um
public private partnership with uh C&J
Trailways to run and operate the um
Portsmouth and Dover Park and Ride
Transportation facilities so that is a
uh that will be a source of of Revenue
we have a base rent and then there is
some Revenue sharing on on top of that
um um yeah so that that is
a um I I'm hopeful that'll be a very
successful project because it's turned
you know what had kind of been a
maintenance drain a a a a um uh you know
a negative cost for us into a positive
so thank you may have a followup Mr CH
quick followup yes um I understand that
the the toll plazas would be under your
jurisdiction with the new plazas and
cars just driving through can you tell
me are we seeing a loss in revenues are
we of vehicles that are excessively
going on uh over the 65 miles that's
required is there any loss of Revenue
there no no there's no loss of Revenue
and we make up we we the fee structure
for um um violations and and things like
that as is purposely looked at and
reviewed to um make up and cover for
those costs of collections thank you
thank you Mr chair okay one more final
question representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for your
presentation
I've never got so much negative com com
comments on um social media this weekend
from the
do
um I don't even know how to describe it
but a weather forecast that that
seemingly uh I was getting comments that
people were asking if it was hacked um
but it shows a a guy with a head coming
out of the toilet driving the the car um
is this is this some kind of um attempt
to um get closer to Millennials or
something like that yeah you that would
that was it I can send you an article
there was a good article uh in the um in
the uh where did I see it in the in the
paper did did did did did compare so you
know part of it was marketing part of it
was to um have a socially engaging
message uh uh lean into some of the
current trends and and try to get that
um um feedback and from a marketing
perspective well it's not something
we're going to do all all the time the
reaction to it the number of views the
number of reposts um were um were were
very successful were very were very high
so while it was a lot of feedback a
around the way the message was was was
conveyed at least there were a lot more
eyes that were seeing the the me the
message
to uh you know watch for weather and dve
D drive slow um it we we did it's it's
interesting there was a we did a very
conventional social media post the day
before intentionally to do a comparison
with that um uh you know with that more
socially trended post the next day and
the comparison in terms of views and
stuff were were night and day so um so
we'll see
more well yeah I we we we want to try to
reach as many people as as as as we can
I won't say it will be all all that way
but we try to have a um broad spectrum
of messaging to engage as many folks as
we can thank you you're
welcome thank you Mr commissioner for uh
coming uh since your team was in here
could you just introduce them to us so
we know who they are because some of
them did come up and answer a question
yep so um Dave rodrigue was the
assistant commissioner uh and chief
engineer um Andre prier and and as I as
I pointed out in the in the in the
structure Dave KES over over oversees
all of the operations and and project
development Andre is the Deputy
Commissioner uh he oversees all of the
non-highway and Bridge Transportation
assets Aeronautics Rail and Transit as
well as the policy and
administration uh with me is uh Steve
lante who is our um legislative liaison
um he's going to be kind of the point
person for interacting with the
committee and and um you know he
monitors and tracks all of the bills and
and things that we're uh following and
things like that and Lee bronis is the
uh administrator of the Bureau of
traffic who do um all of the the signing
striping signals and um he may be a
familiar face because a number of the
bills that tend to come before uh
Transportation uh are pertinent to his
activities so
excellent thank you so much thank you
for having us I appreciate
it and hopefully you found it worthwhile
okay at this point I'd like to uh call
up uh Mr Dan Bennett who's a nice little
friend of the committee to talk a little
bit about who he is and uh what he does
and why we probably see him a lot here
in
transportation welcome Mr
Bennett uh thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee thanks for the
opportunity to speak in uh front of what
is my favorite Committee in the house um
and you will see me often my name is Dan
Bennett I'm the president of the
Hampshire Auto Dealers Association I've
been with the association a little over
20 years um we are a trade group for the
motor vehicle industry so car truck
snowmobile motorcycle ATV construction
farm equipment uh Collision Repair part
stores um pretty much if it's got an
engine or tracks or Wheels we'll take it
um and we represent both franchise and
independent dealers so the the big uh
you know monstrous garage mahals
franchise dealerships to small little
string aite Lots so um in uh about 540
businesses in um communities and Corners
all over the
state uh I'm also going to since you
asked I'll introduce a little bit of our
legislative and government relations
team that helps with us um you'll see in
the back uh retired state police
Lieutenant j o um although he uh won't
be directly lobbying with you he will be
assisting us with our government
relations and compliance work um we also
have the team from den and Boule uh
Jackson Boule is with us as well um for
the Auto Dealers Association as many of
you know Cornerstone issues for us are
safe roads uh consumer protection and
then making sure that our businesses um
have an efficient uh regulatory
environment to work with uh we work very
closely with we appreciate and we're
great partners with um some of the folks
you heard this morning uh specifically
DMV and safety State Police Troop G uh
it's been a lot of time with those folks
um just a little bit about the
association in addition to our
government relations role uh we're a
self-funded workers comp trust um you
know so an insurance company for our
businesses uh since our Inception um in
1990 we've rebated back to those small
businesses that put in um over $100
million uh it helps keep their costs low
um we broker health insurance uh for our
members again to help keep cost low um
and then we have an Education Foundation
um we scholarship young auto technicians
about $85,000 a year we want a homegrown
Workforce
um so we're heavily invested in the 20
high schools that have Automotive
programs as well as the five community
colleges that have both independent
programs and also programs associated
with uh the
manufacturers uh including National
community colleges has a body shop
program uh Collision Repair uh important
um aspect of the industry um importantly
what I want to mention to you all we
also run um and this may help with some
of your constituents if there is a
concern we run an autocap program which
is a Consumer complaint program um so uh
folks can call in um and then we uh try
and bridge the gap with what is usually
a communication difference uh the
customer just didn't know what tires for
life really meant or the message wasn't
making it to the right decision maker in
the sales office or the fni office so we
can help bridge that communication so it
doesn't escalate so the consumer is
happy and made whole so um I'm going to
uh give some handouts uh for the whole
committee that'll have my contact
information on it um which I hope you
use us is a resource um if you have a
question about the industry and the
business uh let us help you um but also
again as I mentioned if you have a
constituent concern that we can assist
with please let us know um other than
that just wanted to say thank you very
much for the opportunity and uh we look
forward to working with you this
session thank you much Dan any questions
for
Dan not seeing any thank you sir
thanks next person i' like to call up is
Mr Tom prol
we will see Tom quite a bit in committee
uh Tom welcome to trans welcome back to
Transportation great thank you very much
uh Vice chairman uh so everyone knows my
name is Tom prol from demur prol and
Thomas um we're a lobbying firm here in
uh coner and we have about 40 clients uh
many of which uh will come before this
Committee just to name a few um we
represent the New Hampshire driver
education Teachers Association we
represent Enterprise renar along along
with several clients who have Trucking
uh issues including FedEx and Walmart
and retail association we also represent
the New Hampshire Police Association and
New Hampshire Troopers Association who
may be before you with some uh some
other issues um with that I'm always in
the Halls if you have any questions
please feel free to grab me and while I
don't usually make promises I promise I
will always do my best to not be the
last one standing between you and lunch
so with that I will stand up
thank you Mr Vice chair uh one more
person that would like to introduce
themselves who's a a regular in
transportation Mr Bob
Scully
repres for members of the committee my
name is Bob Scully I've appeared in
front of this committee for SE over 37
years I almost got the numbers backwards
I represent large commercial motor
vehicles um big trucks New Hampshire
Motor Transport Association we have over
300 members all the way from UPS fed tax
down to single owner operators our
issues are safety
um no taxes if we can help them we pay
enough we feel we just like to keep that
in check and uh over 95% of everything
that comes in this state comes by truck
so no matter what you have for clothes
where you go to eat materials you buy
for your house it all comes in this
state by truck so um I'm often here in
front of this committee um I know it's
the end of the long morning for you so I
thank you um I'll be in the hallways if
you need me and I will appear in front
of you on legislation of interest to us
and I thank you for the
opportunity thank you very much right uh
anybody else would like to introduce I
think everybody has that wants to okay
well that's the end of our presentations
um and again I said I do have a normal
checklist of things that we can go over
uh that are more committee
specific 15 minutes half an hour I'm
looking I'll ask your opinion what do
you want to do do you want to just go
right through do you want to stop for
lunch or how about a 15 minute
break power
through I thought you were going to give
us 10 minutes
but okay I tell you what let's do 10 10
minutes that's not really a break
so
for
e
e e
I guess uh I still need to be public for
this um I hope everybody thought that uh
the presentations this morning were
valuable we have a lot of
information uh we do have the pleasure
of dealing with a lot of good people so
we've got that going for us um as you
can see I didn't keep today very
structured uh I figured if I did we'd be
here till 2:30 3 o' with all the people
we heard from so doing it like this we
actually got a lot of info uh the only
thing I got left for today just for
committee sake um I do have a list of
things we can run through in terms of
how this committee operates or most
committees operate give me one second
here I'll go through these I'll read
them and uh share my opinion if I have
have one if we have any questions or
your opinion let me
know um start time and notices of
absence so obviously check the calendar
every week uh for the start times of our
hearings or executive
sessions as you'll notice uh with a rule
change from last week uh if you see a
disclaimer in the calendar we do have
the ability to fill in any downtime uh
by executing bills that we've either
heard that day or
previously um I think for just for the
benefit of the new people I think most
of you that are veterans know I usually
schedule everything um best as possible
including the exact sessions uh and I do
try to I think I've got a pretty good
success record on estimating how much
time for the hearings too um not all the
time but it's not an easy thing to
do
um I recommendation for everybody on the
committee single email account used for
legislative business uh I was hesitant
at first but I have since done it I
would strongly recommend using the
legislative address for for whatever you
do here uh and keep your personal one
separate uh believe it or not it could
be requested of you one of these days
you never know so uh keep everything
separate and again don't hesitate to
stop me as I run through
these uh dress and decorum another rule
that failed but
I we all do our best to look
professional I actually underdressed
today so if you see me coming in like
this with no tie and jeans it's probably
because I spent a couple hours on my job
before I get here and this is pretty
good multi-purpose clothing but it's
still an effort uh but I everybody
should we should be dressing as
professionals there's no doubt about it
um today we just had department heads I
shouldn't say just but a lot of times um
we'll have members of the public too you
know and that's what we're here to do uh
there are sometimes we won't be in this
room um I don't think we have the
opportunity this year uh but we have in
the past had U public hearings in the
Hall of reps with 250 300 people I mean
so it can
happen food coffee and lunch breaks all
right this is where I do chime in a
little bit um water is okay and and as
you can see even if it's something other
than water I ask you that you keep it
down below the table these benches
actually the tables do have these little
convenience shelves underneath I just
think and again not today where this is
informal today but when we have hearings
going on or exec sessions I try to keep
drinks and stuff off the table I think
it looks a lot better food obviously
we're not eating food unless we do a
special lunch uh for the committee but
uh obviously again back to that
professional um appearance use of
electronic devices this has been a
matter of contention for years uh some
in the past would say no anything no
laptops no phones I have seen that
decision come down from the speaker
office in the past there is no such Rule
now it's up to
us I guess I'll say let's go for it you
can use them they are a good resource
but again keep in mind when people are
speaking to us it doesn't always look
good if we have a I prefer not to see
laptops tablets or phones I get it uh
and if you're going to use your laptop
be be sparing about it
we are trying to listen to the people
that are here
so we'll we'll leave it at that and if
we see anything happening I'll make
mention of it but uh use of electronic
devices we just covered fora committee
for our new folks in the in the office
we do have some cabinets uh some filing
draws they're good size um I
believe actually let me back up I've
been remiss our committee researcher is
Mr Brad grin and I apologize
Brad and in the office out this door to
the right in office
2011a millenial not a j z um is our
committee assistant um Karen
Davis yeah she can come in and introduce
herself sure uh and I can ask her a
question at the same time or maybe you
know are all the names been updated on
the filing cabinets yes we'll take a
look afterwards for everybody just to
make sure you've got your your own dra
allotted to you you've already got yours
I've checked okay so I'm assuming that's
these people are right on top of
it um I will be assigning a member for
security
notifications unfortunately he just left
um so hopefully we're good for the
day and fire alarm exit in our room I'll
make sure everybody can see it posted
clearly what happens how to get out of
here if there's an
emergency Okay so committee our partisan
balance is nine Republicans and seven
Democrats this is a big switch for
transportation I've been here since 2013
or 2012 election and it was always a 20
member committee so with the development
of a second education committee you know
and and a good number of people that
didn't want any committee that's why the
decision was to reduce some of the
numbers um where they could I don't know
might make our life easier might not I
guess we'll see how it goes
uh but that is the that is the uh the
split
97 uh everybody good with the seat I
gave you today this was just a a rough
one I try to mix everybody up no
objections then I guess we'll leave the
seating as it
is typical Bill
topics well as you get into this you
will probably see that the majority of
our bills or what's called Title 20 uh
Motor Vehicle Laws I won't go too far
into that right now we you'll see you're
going to get one book of statutes it
contains Title 20 I'd say 99% of the
bills that we 95 95% of 95% of the bills
we cover are within Title 20
occasionally with references
elsewhere second committee
work we will be getting well we usually
do um again we haven't got bills yet
probably not even close uh second bills
that will require us to act go to the
floor and then go to a second committee
usually it's either Finance if it's got
a fiscal note possibly uh criminal
justice or Judiciary if it if it changes
uh penalties substantially so you may
see some of those types of bills we'll
deal with those first as soon as I get
all the bills I'll let everybody know
which ones are considered early um
um
subcommittees we'll deal with that as we
go we can have we can and do have the
ability if we have bills in particular
that we kind of like the idea but know
it needs work we can at at our exec
sessions or um yeah the exact session
would be the appropriate Place request
subcommittees and we can do groups of
usually odd number three five people if
they want to uh if if there's a desire
to study a bill uh and work on it toing
bring it back to this committee the full
committee to vote on it before it goes
to the floor and I'm just going through
these quick any questions don't worry
there's more there'll be plenty of
opportunity uh calendar notices I think
I've already
mentioned our Bible weekly um I
generally do not reach out to the
committee
personally um via email um I know we're
allowed for notifications and such uh
without any violations to 91a but I
still think it's simpler um this is what
I use to reach out to you um uh I I
think it works better it's more
efficient Bill files do not leave the
building that would be more for me
because obviously the bills you've been
issued can leave the building they're
yours by the way um this is only 15 of
them right now we have 24 that have
already been
issued uh I just heard this morning
there are still
I think he said better than 200 that
have not even been assigned
yet then I also heard um and they're
pretty good at usually figuring out
where they go based on Title
20 I wouldn't be surprised if and and
agree with DMV that we probably get 45
which is not the most we've had we had
54 last year I think I mean I was very
happy with the 24 I don't know about the
rescue but but we'll see what happens uh
and I'll and in terms of scheduling I
I'll bring this up now while we're
talking about the
bills I generally like to have them all
so that when I do my scheduling I can
group them together by theme so that you
know a lot of the people are testify of
the same ones and we're we're into it
you know you've seen it before we have
bills that multiple bills that touch on
the same thing I have without having all
of them I'm hesitant on scheduling
anything for next
week uh but I may do that and and on
that note Tuesday is going to be the day
we meet um it's always been Sophia
planning purposes Tuesday is our
day
um committee
oh well the ranking member and both the
vice chair we know about the committee
replacement policy if you can't make it
to a committee day
basically El executive sessions because
there's really no need to replace
yourself for a day just at has public
hearings uh you do need to let the
respective offices know whether it's
democrat or republican the day before
before they close otherwise they cannot
assign any
Replacements all right let's touch on
public hearings for a minute next excuse
me B
drink I have seen in the past public
hearings we had a member in the past I
won't mention any names who thought that
the public hearings we had were modeled
on um
investigatory panels or uh meetings
commissions of the United States Senate
and the way they grilled people sitting
at that table that's not what we do here
um we're here to listen to what they
have to offer and ask questions of them
what's relative to the bill we don't get
into debates with the public um there a
little levity but if it's a department
head but but for the most part it's just
a sharing of information they tell us
and we can ask them if they're willing
to take questions uh but no speeches
during public hearings when you're
asking questions if you've been called
to ask a question uh no time for speech
is there that literally is uh asking
through the chair uh to a question of
who's ever at that
table um you'll see I'm fair with giving
questions probably fairer than most U
but if I'm looking at the clock and if I
if I start saying no to more questions
it's only because I'm looking ahead and
and if we don't stop we're going to get
in trouble the clock does run everything
eventually um but you you'll you'll
catch it for those of you that knew not
been through this um
speeches that's you have a little more
opportunity for that when we're debating
the bill in the committee and that's the
executive session whole different rules
in executive session um you still got to
go through the chair but that's your
opportunity for debate opportunity
opportunity for speeches and again I
mention it questions go through the
chair um and if you need a second
question you should you know ask for a
second question and U basically
everything goes through me or the vice
chair when he's sitting here
here when the sponsor is a member of the
committee all right so if you have a
bill and I think you do that'll be
coming
here okay so what happens if
[Music]
you I'll I'll do the sponsor first if
you are a sponsor of a bill and you go
up and you're on this committee you'll
go up to that table introduce the bill
like everybody else does but that's your
bite at the Apple
and and so you won't be returning to
your seat unless it's a full house I
might make an exception to let you back
to your seat but that's only because
it's a full house generally if I
introduce one of my bills I stay out in
the gallery because that's the last time
I get to speak on it uh and that applies
to everybody if it's a full house I'll
let you come back over here but if you
come and sit down it's not to ask
questions it's not to offer any more
testimony it's just how it works um
co-sponsors are different if you're a
co-sponsor on a
bill and you don't don't go to that
table it's okay if you ask questions of
the witnesses that are there um so
there's no there's pretty everybody
clear on that it's it's it's pretty much
common sense um and again a lot of these
things I'm going through because this is
my outline as we get into it you see how
it all works it it all makes
sense yeah okay yeah I already mentioned
this action on the bill same days of
hearing rule 44b we do have the ability
to do that now I promise I will not be
abusing it but if it's uh bills that we
think we can just dispose of with no
Fanfare and a little debate just to get
them out of if we're in agreement
basically uh we it might come in handy
um again I am of the thought process of
longer days just fewer I hope everybody
can go along with that
because everybody's time is important so
that could come in very handy
conflict of interest in recusal
committee procedure rules 100 through
111 sorry we passed a it's you've all
filled out your financial disclosure
forms you also have a new one to fill
out before Friday I don't know if all of
you have done it get on the portal or
get into the
portal the one you filled out at the
very beginning is not the last one now
we have a new one um
uh and it's a little
more what's that charie charliie
especially uh so there's no way I'm
going to go into it at this depth now I
would suggest reading everything that's
there there are going to be more up for
more times that recusal may be something
you need to do depending on the new law
so I instead of getting we could talk
about this for hours I will just make
mention that you need to look into this
uh
um and we'll see how it goes like this
is a new law we're going to see how it
rolls out but with conflicts of interest
and recusal in this new bill it's a
possibility that that some may have to
do it more often than they thought in
the past and that could be up for debate
too I guess with with the administration
but we'll see how it goes I just want to
make make you aware that we did make a
lot of change last
year EX
sessions no public input without the
chair's consent
meaning uh when we go into executive
session it's it's our time um the only
time somebody in the gallery will chime
in is if I allow them because we have a
question and that's more than fine but
it's not a time for more public uh input
or public hearings it's specifically for
information during that executive
session
process anybody have any questions on
amendments
because well I'll go through it if you
want to amend the
bill you need to go to
ol ol the only amendments we will take
here are by committee members or can
take here by committee members prepared
by
OS once you've seen the amendment then
you request that that gets sent up to
committee Services committee services
will make the appropriate amount of
copies for the committee and bring them
down to us so that's basically the
process I don't think I'm missing
anything of I I would specifically say
that you should be aware you should be
aware of any
am it's helpful now any amendments if
you heard that any amendments uh well
the chair does have the ability to
recognize them or not um I don't
normally have an issue with that but uh
it I guess like anything else I try to
keep open communication with the ranking
member uh just it's helpful for
everybody if we all do the same if you
get an amendment coming on a bill the
more people know about it the better off
nobody likes surprises I guess in other
words uh so anyway no public input
without chair's consent uh amendments
prepared by OS if you have any other
questions or any hesitation on how to
draft an amendment or get one drafted I
should say please reach out U we'll do
everything we can to help you uh
motions we have
um well three motions um in expedient to
legislate is if you don't want the bill
to move forward op to pass if you
do we'll get into the parliament the
first executive session will be an eye
opener for those of who have never done
it if none of our new members have never
done it uh on some of the other motions
um we can do
reconsideration uh we can go through the
whole gambut of everything we would do
on the house floor for the most part
with the exception of tabling
we can't we can't table a bill here can
we no we we also
have right right we we almost were able
to table them we do have another couple
of options with bills in the fir well in
the first year we can set up to what's
called interim study if we truly believe
that that U no retained sorry U retained
on the first year and we do that is
exactly what it means it won't go to the
floor um there'll be no committee report
on it we will keep the bill and work on
it until the following year of the
bium uh and then we'll have to dispose
on it dispose of it and then the second
year interim
study uh yeah Tech it is what it is it's
also called death With Dignity but
you'll see how this works when we get to
that stage that's that's next year's
fund um
we can adopt amendments in committee by
a Voice vote but all votes for the
committee recommendation will be done by
roll
call after we vote on a bill uh we do
have to uh create a committee
report
so I tend to whoever gets makes the
motion ask the person to come up with
the committee
report if it's not a unanimous bill then
obviously that's the opportunity for the
minority to offer their Minority Report
and both of those reports have to be I
want them that
day um they do get proof read by several
people first myself uh then they go
through committee Services ultimately
they get looked at Again by the speaker
and the
clerk
um once again it's basically just a
reporting and an explanation to the Full
House of what we did and why we did it
um when I'm just going through this when
we get to that point I will gladly work
with anybody who's never done one um
just to make it easier and then you'll
also start seeing them in the calendar
when you start seeing how some of these
other ones look that'll give you a gauge
on on what they should look like but
they're not that bad simple as
better we again I do I did mention we we
have Brad as our researcher and Karen is
our assistant they are here to help us
but they also help a bunch of other
committees as well if you need or would
request that they give you a hand on
something that's relative to this
committee only that request still needs
to come through me um otherwise if if 16
people from four different five
different committees were going after
them all at once uh they would be
overwhelmed so it's just a matter of
keeping some order and keeping some uh
some sanity through the process
us uh and they do our committee work
only I think I mentioned
that we're almost done folks remember
resources uh we do have administrative
support on the fourth floor I strongly
recommend to anybody that's new never
hesitate going up to the fourth floor
and asking questions U that's the one
thing that makes this whole place work
is the staff that we have up there
um we do have statutes here um
on top of the filing cabin in the back
room you'll also see I believe those are
up to date probably the last 15 years of
updates to Title 20 you know our related
book um obviously there are complete
statutes because I don't think these
have been maintained that well up on the
fourth
floor computer level in our old smoking
room uh yes we did have one up until not
too long
ago what's that on the fourth floor of
the L smoking room yes I mean a computer
room
uh okay uh I do have the password for
the internet access if you need it it
should be pretty much everybody's got it
but I do have it if you need
it the rest of the things I have here
are just phone numbers for the clerk for
Richard Lambert Ethics Committee
executive director and for an Fitzgerald
who uh is lead staff at house committee
services that is all I've got is just a
rough description of how this all works
representative gski do you have
anything yeah I just I think one of the
things that makes this committee great
is the collegiality that we may have
differences of opinion but this is a
really great committee that you know we
like to kind of keep that that culture
so I think the key thing here so we we
treat each other with respect um and you
know there could be differences of
opinion but I think this is what makes
this committee one of the best ones I
believe um we can just kind of keep that
that'll be
fantastic anybody else represent St
Clair I just a quick question any is
there anything going on with the
driver's licenses being not used for
other information you know with that
strip on the back and we talked about
that we had a bill last year on that is
there do you know of anything coming
down the pike on that this year
area so this is where they uh you go
into a bar or something and they scan
it I tried to introduce a bill last year
regarding that uh another person had so
they didn't let me introduce mine I did
see one I'm not I don't know if it get
signed off on but I in the early LSR
stage I saw that there was a bill to
prohibit the scanning of alcohol and
tobacco
products which is the only Bill I've
seen so far which is actually all I
wanted out of mine uh but the one that
got let in instead of mine went quite a
ways away I don't know if you remember
that I I met every lobbyist in this
building people I haven't seen in years
over that one bill that was brutal but
that's the only one I know of and I
haven't got it
yet uh another interesting too uh
interesting one too speaking of bills I
had a conversation with somebody with a
full-blown repeal of the inspection
program
again I haven't seen it I don't know if
something happened I don't know if he
missed the
deadline it could be in the 200 but then
again I looked in all the lsrs too I
didn't see it so uh it's a possibility
uh that I did see it but that doesn't
mean it made it you know with all the
deadlines and sign Ops and everything
something could have happened
technically uh caucuses um again he's a
partisan so um basically how it works
I'm I'm the the neutral as the chair of
the neutral person in in in the room uh
the ranking member will manage the
caucuses for the Democrats and the vice
chairman organizes caucuses for the
Republicans um usually we'll take this
room for our caucus
um
and we do share time to time and then
the Democrats can take the
office we've always been pretty flexible
um I don't know how many rooms are going
to be available so if you think
there if you don't want the office if
you think it's too small uh we may I'll
have to check in with with Karen to see
if we need to schedule rooms for
caucuses but we haven't had to up until
this point usually just to sneak in
empty room for 15 20 minutes but but
those are the two people responsible for
them uh when you do them is up to you um
in terms of on we'll we'll we'll talk
later uh on
further further information on the
caucuses what am I fetting go ahead you
mentioned executive sessions earlier are
those still televised public record or
are those private okay they are public
well they're televised everything we do
is stream now uh but if the cameras go
out we don't stop and that's why the
public record still is officially the
clerk's notes um that's another reason I
didn't do any hearings today because I
knew she was out of state U I usually
try to fill the afternoon up on
organization days with hearings but with
with a few people missing and not having
all the bills that's why I figured we'd
have a nice easy
day anybody
else well I think you've heard me rant
long enough for those of you that don't
know me I try to keep it light here uh I
do let the I do watch the CL pretty good
but in terms of how we uh how we
interact we need to laugh occasionally
so that's uh been the been the tradition
here and hopefully we can keep it up so
I will ponder actually we could be
getting bills issued to us right now I
don't
know and I and I would just say watch
the
calendar about any public hearings for
next Tuesday if I want to give you as
odds
70% chance we'll be doing some hearings
on Tuesday and I know it's not a good
way to do this but I really want to see
the whole
pile
so yep so in my
Committee in my committee we end up with
a bunch of bills that are perennials
um we see them frequently so one of the
things I'm asking our researcher to do
is to provide us um the last time that
it happened a copy of the file I don't
know if I I recall from any of the bills
in here um whether there were I just
want to see what what previous testimony
occurred and what happened with the bill
so we're not doing kind of what you're
just saying whatever happened with that
bill that had the um I don't know if I
saw ones that are back from last term
but I think it's helpful for especially
those for that aren't here now um or
that weren't there then to catch up
somewhat I I'll look at that
specifically it's a good idea um I
thought I saw one that was a return oh
yeah well one that is a return from last
year is uh eliminating the first year
inspections that's a repeat I don't
think the text has changed at all so we
can get that
information um if the
full-blown repeal of the program gets
found or if it actually did get filed I
I can do the same thing with that
however I was told that this one was
going to be doing a pretty deep dive
into all the statutes including the
references on that repeal that one could
be a beauty so uh if anybody else
notices uh bills
that well we don't have window ENT bills
this year so that takes care that that
perennial uh I haven't seen a uh outou
ofate plates on outou ofate trailers
getting license plates yet so that that
could be a
perennial
driver driver's license um I haven't
seen the 15 we've got I'll flip through
them later there's a couple drivers last
oh that's right that's another one yes
BS that's that I don't I haven't looked
at the Lang language yet but that
probably probably didn't change
y go ahead Brad oh that's right another
one rolling
coal what do they call that Prius
repellent
yeah yes so we do have some fun yeah the
more than I thought that are coming back
so
yeah
yeah that's right you did you did the
majority report on that that's
right well that's all I've got again
blue envelope is in there too so I don't
know if that would have been an ideal to
table under this if if we had gotten it
yeah I still have to have a hearing um
and we still
have or they could withdraw it do you I
know is partial on that he is he's not
oh fogner I think the blue envelope
bill I think like the third
or yeah we brought this to the dmad spor
he said I can do
this first listed it's in our package
look into if you can
well all right anything else for the
good of the
cause seeing done thanks very much and
uh watch the calendar for my decision on
next
Tuesday for